so for the past five years laura morris
has been a teacher in loudoun county
virginia public schools that is until
tuesday on tuesday she quit her job in
front of the school board why did she do
that
well she explained here's part of it i
was told in one of my so-called equity
trainings that white christian
able-bodied females currently have the
power in our schools and that quote this
has to change clearly you've made your
point you no longer value me or many
other teachers you've employed in this
county so since my contract outlines the
power that you have
over my employment in loudoun county
public schools i thought it necessary to
resign in front of you
school board i quit i quit your policies
i quit your trainings and i quit being a
cog in a machine that tells me to push
highly politicized agendas on our most
vulnerable constituents the children i
will find employment elsewhere i
encourage all parents and staff in this
county to flood the private schools
ah laura morris is the teacher you saw
she joins us tonight laura thanks so
much for coming on there's something
really moving about the end of that
video you i'm taking from your emotion
that you didn't want to quit he's
why did you quit
well first of all tucker thank you so
much for inviting me on your show i
can't tell you what an honor this is um
and to answer your question yes it was
very emotional and it was a very hard
decision to come to it was not taken
lightly um
some people have asked why i chose to do
it in that manner and the truth is
i just knew all that i was leaving
behind the sacrifice and that decision
was great for me um the biggest of the
the sacrifice being my students that i
wasn't going to see anymore the staff
that i work with
that i wasn't going to see
um every day anymore so i wanted i
wanted them to see why i was leaving and
it must be my naivete i didn't imagine
um that other people would see it i mean
i guess i knew that that would happen
but i wasn't thinking beyond that night
so what has happened out of this as a
result just the um
the outreach has been unlike i would
ever imagine it's been a life-changing
experience and i'm just honored and i'm
humbled by it all
well there's so few brave people right
now that when you see one it really
sticks with you and you are one what
what effect do you think all of this is
having on the kids in this in school
um you know
you mentioned brave and that just it
doesn't feel like it can describe me
because i this was all done by the grace
of god the the protection i've had the
provision i've had since
doing what i did just the courage to get
up and do it comes from just my walk
with the lord and as far as the impact
on the students i've received so many
texts so many emails from
students of families of students that
i've taught in the past and they're just
they are just so
um happy for me that i i made the
decision that i did because they know
that um it was what was right for me and
they're so
with me there's so much support they're
just
they're they're all just letting me know
we have your back we loved you my
students loved you and
it's just been
wonderful
teaching kids that some races are better
than others is so immoral that i just
wonder will more teachers quit before
they teach that
you know uh
one of the emails i received from
someone from another state it put it
beautifully i couldn't have said it
better myself if philip from connecticut
sent me an email and said
i've it's been said that one candle can
illuminate a thousand others without
diminishing its own illumination and he
said you are that candle and i was so
moved by those words because i never
would have thought of myself in that
position but i don't feel at all
diminished by what's happened in fact i
feel
the amazing blessings of god just
pouring down on me from what has
happened and i'm so excited that what i
did and said might spark others might
illuminate
in others the desire to
put some action to their words there's a
lot of words going on right now in
counties people are upset on both sides
there's a lot of opinions flying around
and i'm just noticing more and more that
that doesn't seem to be changing things
but when people do something bold when
people put action to their words actions
speak louder than words and that seems
to be captivating people so i'm excited
to see
what other actions people might be
taking yes i hope others will conclude
that they cannot participate in this
because it's just too it's just too
wrong laura morris i appreciate you
coming on tonight good luck
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else